(upbeat music)
- All right, welcome back!
That was Lester Holt,
jamming with my band y'all!
Lester And I read a lot of
teleprompter at our jobs y'all.
Sometimes I even ended up
reading it without thinking
just like the legendary
anchorman, Mr. Ron Burgundy.
Just look..
I literally call myself Ron Burgundy
because I say everything
that's in the teleprompter.
You could just put anything
in there, and I read it.
(laughing)
And future sexiest man alive.
Oh wait, it's a question.
Cause he's not yet. (indistinct sound)
I'm Ron Burgundy, man.
You put it in, and I'm gonna say it.
I don't care, I'm running with it.
(laughing)
Ron Burgundy.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I'm Ron Burgundy.
I'll literally do anything
they put in there.
No shame.
Okay, fine.
Everyone to do the same? Oh,
encouraging (blows raspberry)
(everyone laughing)
And people, that is just
a third of the bloopers
that we showed you.
That's why this game is
called I'm Ron Burgundy.
(upbeat music)
Here's how the game works.
Lester and I have to
read real news stories
from the prompter.
So these are real news stories.
These stories actually happened.
No fake news here people.
The catch is we've never
seen these stories.
And my producers who
love to mess with me have
probably changed the words
to make them harder to read.
Thank you in advance.
Each time we mess up or laugh,
Oh man, I'm going to laugh,
we get a mark.
Whoever has the lowest number
of marks at the end of the game wins.
Okay. Lester is playing for the men
in the audience I'm
playing for the ladies.
(applause)
A super cool prize is on the line.
Don't worry ladies. I've got this.
Lester you're up first.
- Okay, so read the prompter, it's cold?
- Absolutely. You've never seen it.
I've never seen it.
- Good evening.
A homeowner in Erie, Pennsylvania woke
at 3:00 AM to find a man drinking milk
and singing in his kitchen.
The man was on the kitchen floor naked,
as in birthday, where ah
(buzzer sounds followed by laughter)
As in, wearing his birthday suit.
Stop.
(buzzer sounds)
In the buck.
(indistinct) Buck Markey,
starkers, bunga bunga,
hot cross buns with a side
of lookie what we have here.
Floating around in his
own personal pool party
if you catch my drift.
Nake n' Bake, beach bum, air-drying.
The old neighborly How'd-you-do
He was a naturist.
(buzzer sounds)
(laughter)
Nature is bare down
there like a grizzly bear
during the care bear stare,
a real frequent flyer.
Just taking a short nacation.
He had no clothes on people.
(laughter)
No injuries were reported
and it's not clear how
the man entered the home
or what his motive was.
(laughter)
I dare you to match it with that voice.
- (laughing) That was
awesome, I had no idea.
I'm so scared right now.
Okay. (makes noises)
Got this.
Okay.
- All right
- Lester made three mistakes.
So my turn.
Okay, here we go.
This is my, this is my official.
Let me take a, here we go.
- She's stalling.
- Yes. Yes.
Okay. Here we go.
In Europe, a flock of farts
forced to plane to take evasive action.
A flight from Dubai to
Amsterdam was rerouted
after one passenger wouldn't
stop baking air biscuits.
The flatulent flier caused a stink
with his constant gas leak.
His seatmates complained,
but the man merely replied,
(makes farting sound)
(buzzer sounds, audience laughs)
The captain stopped in Vienna
where those who complained
were removed allowing Farty
McFarterson to continue
toot, toot, tooting to the Netherlands.
(laughing)
I did well!
- You did very well.
(applause)
- I had flatulence, yours was harder.
- I wouldn't have gotten
through flatulence.
- Yours was harder.
Okay, after round one
Lester has three mistakes,
I have one mistake.
What's up ladies.?!
(cheering)
Okay. You're up again.
- All right, this one, pshhhh
- Okay
- In Portland, a goat busted
into a seven 11 on Scholls Ferry Road.
The bearded beast boogered
by the chalupas, big gulps,
and undulating foot
longs in order to snack
on some sour Skittles.
One patron said quote, "Dude
not one realize that there's
a real life goat in here?"
No comment was given by the goat,
although one might
imagine the rainbow tasted
like baba Lala- meaaaak-
baba lalalal (goat noises)
to the marauding animal.
(laughter)
- Oh my god, oh gosh (laughing)
Yours are way harder.
- Well, I'm a trained professional.
- I know, I love that
they're doing it to you.
Okay, that was zero marks
for Lester, which is amazing,
cause we made him do it like a goat.
It's fun.
My turn again.
(coughs)
Here we go.
An Alabama fugitive who allegedly fed
mmm
(buzzer sounds)
methamphetamines to his pet
squirrel named Deez Nuts,
(laughter and buzzer sounds)
- You got through flatulence
but you couldn't do Neez Nuts.
- Deez Nuts!
Named Deez Nuts, is being
charged with a state
wildlife offense, um offense.
(laughter and buzzer)
offense playing sports
- She's skimming the trees
ladies and gentlemen.
- No, I, shoot.
Okay. The man did not deny
housing a nut loving NAR
but didn't deny he fed
the little guy meth to
turn him into an attack squirrel.
This is a real story?
(buzzer)
(laughter)
That just hit me.
I want to punish that man.
Okay. When asked about the animal
the man said he'd had the squirrel
since it was a baby and would
never give Deez Nuts drugs.
Reporters found Deez Nuts
unavailable for comment.
(laughs)
(buzzer sounds)
- [Lester] Thank goodness.
(laughter)
- Deez Nuts
I'm still 15, it doesn't matter.
Okay. The score is now
Lester with three mistakes
and me with six mistakes, whatever.
That means the winner is Lester.
(music plays)
(crowd goes wild)
(indistinct)
- No, so Lester's won as well as all the..
What?
Oh, see that happened to me again.
Okay. See it just happened.
They moved, they changed.
- Do you need me to read this?
- They just changed it on me!
- She wants to say, as well
as the men in the house seats.
(laughter)
- As well as Deez Nuts, you're all getting
a giveaway! Everyone's a
winner including Deez Nuts.
Epson Eco Tank Printers are
an innovative cartridge free
solution, that use high
capacity, easily refillable
ink tanks instead of expensive cartridges
which makes this an ideal everyday printer
for families, and everyone in
our audience is getting one.
(pew pew pew pew pewwww)
Even Deez Nuts.
And because Lester won,
his photo will be hung
on the Blake Shelton wall
of Champions who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(laughing)
No one likes that wall.
So whatever! Be sure to
watch Lester anchoring
NBC Nightly News, Dateline
and NBC Nightly News
Kids Edition on nbc.com.